all righty then just wait for foxy hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the joy of creation
story mode now this may be one of the
last videos I make about this game but
there's one more mystery in this game
that I wanted to solve and it has to do
with the newspapers so you guys told me
someone gave me a hint not really a him
that kind of explained it pretty much
that in every level golden freddy is
somewhere and I was wondering about that
because in the first game or the first
time I found a newspaper was in the
office and in the office I didn't really
recognize it at the time I don't even
know if I called it out in the video but
I encountered golden Freddy and didn't
really realize it when I was opening the
doors in the opening sequence that's how
I got the paper when it opened up and
there was golden Freddy there it looked
just like Freddy wood but then
immediately after that I found the
newspaper and that's just because I was
spastically going around the whole room
so in this episode I'm gonna find all of
the newspapers by this method and so I'm
gonna go through each of these ones that
I have not done yet which is all of
these except and even the ending I don't
know where in the ending it is because
there is golden Freddy in the last one
but I don't know where the newspaper is
so that's probably gonna be the hardest
one to actually find but let's go
through this one at a time and see how
we do looking for golden Freddy and only
the opening dialogue and then see where
it goes from there
sound good let's do this okay bye whoa
what is that oh that's from one of his
other games there's something from
either five nights of Rachel's birth was
that pop-goes is that is my guess is
that golden Freddy appears where Freddy
normally appears because that spends the
oh oh my god right that was how was in
the house oh
okay just lie down that was
fantastically easy that was rapidly fast
but I'm right so that's what that is a
boot so can I get out of this oh quit
the menu okay I don't even need to die
maybe I'd to beat the level no I got it
oh my god
in real life I tend to have waking
nightmares meaning that I walk in my
sleep etc one night I dreamt that bonnie
was in the hall outside my door as I
jumped out of the bed and rush to hold
the door shut I discovered that the door
was locked and it filled me with dread
in five nights at freddys when the doors
don't work it means something is already
in the room interesting alright but
carrying on that's only one of them we
got three more to find but I don't know
where in the basement it would be wait
in the basement I think I do know where
that would be because golden Freddy
appears on the screen there he appears
on the screen that moment when the three
doors open then I'll get to that when I
get to it but that's just something for
the future I know I know that's what
that is whatever occurs just don't let
them I know I know just
you're in the living room eyes that try
to focus just stare into this case how
do you know my husband's name I'm almost
at I was there when he found you Michael
he never said his name how do you know
Michael Michael Michael okay so it's not
staring into this so staring into that
for a while yeah I'm sure it's in that
opening sequence because the other
otherwise it wouldn't make any sense
whoa
peekaboo hey how's it going come I mean
three one come on three oh come on it's
making me look bad oh just stare into
his little eyes yours hey buddy hey
how's it going
oh you're Bri but in let me ask you
something do you know where uh you know
I could find myself a golden Freddy have
you had any inkling of where that might
be no all righty then just wait okay
okay all right all I did was I I wait I
went over and looked as soon as he said
keyholes so like right when he said
keyholes I went over there I think that
was the timing okay I got it
oh man that was it again like when it
happens it's like oh that was easy
new horror phenomenon has massive
success with young children every kid
knows about Freddy he's like Santa Claus
or King Kong great comparisons to make
but what what kind of puzzle is this
making like are these connecting to
something or other why are they here is
the question there must be some deeper
meaning to all of this okay so the thing
about this one is that it has no intro
sequence so and Freddy is not here
there's a poster of Freddy
but I've already checked that boaster
many many times and I don't think it's
there so there's got to be something
else hidden away there is that golden
Freddy sequence in number four but if
it's before that I have no idea hey
buddy how you going friend okay so it's
got to be in the fourth one it's got to
be in the fourth one there's like what
it oh wait um light of night
nope 1983 1984 all right you can't get
up there hello oh I thought that was it
I thought that oh I thought that was it
Oh Frick all right I don't see it if
it's here you missed it but I don't
think it is I still think it's in I
still think it's in the other area I'm
just trying to be thorough and
double-check everything and nothing can
you go back oh you can't go back I
didn't know you could go back what's
happens if I go back you're a newspaper
in there whose baby whose baby no aunt
Judy's that was if you see whatever the
view walk backwards see this thing no I
got a bad feeling about this
Oh keep going well already looking back
if I were to hide something it would be
would be looking back wouldn't it [ __ ]
no I think just death death here
wait what the [ __ ] how did that get
turned around don't stand around danger
is always nearby
did it turn me around I was walking
backwards I thought I was bet no I don't
think I did get turned around I think it
just spawns behind me so I can make it
all the way back to the bathroom and if
I do make it all the way back to the
bathroom and I go in there after I get
caught then maybe there's something in
that bathroom you know what I mean
either way just just to be sure I'm I'm
fine you did that back too bad
turn around looking back oh okay then
but I got it that was I had a different
thing in mind so it did turn me around
okay all right good thing I experimented
oh my god that one took forever by the
way no good now I just got to find the
last frickin one which I don't know
where I'm gonna find it because golden
Freddy is literally everywhere there it
may just be scattered - no not that I'm
gonna look at though it may just be
scattered somewhere in that office I
have no idea though that one's probably
gonna be a [ __ ] to find - serial
arsonist arrested man suspected for
multiple forest fires in the state is
taken into custody after latest incident
well in the world of five nights at
Freddy's there are a lot of fires that
get started a lot of fires all right
anyway let's see attic Oh someone's
gonna be pure brain power so golden
Freddy sometimes spawns behind you right
that's a thing so there's nothing there
well there's that's Freddie what does
that mean anything is the question is
there like any it would be physically
here right it wouldn't be in the cameras
that wouldn't make any sense for me to
reach through the cameras right so
golden Freddy appears he's moving fast
he's moving faster than the fire to be
honest wait nothing he's even on fire
wait what does that mean nothing's on
fire yeah nothing's on fire good whoa
there you are all right well I see you
that's the thing about this one like
golden Freddy's everywhere so does it
actually mean anything nope monka is
golden Freddy again hey buddy
oh it's uh it's Ted come on in wipe your
feet I'll be out a lovely day we got
dinner prepared for you turn my back
all right so didn't find it weird
there's only so many places you can look
so you have to do something right you
have to do something to get it it would
be like you can't shop here you have to
you would have to do something right so
it doesn't matter if there's a fire so
golden fret it's always been about
golden Freddy right warm Freddy and the
cameras on Freddy in the end it's gotta
be something to do with film Freddy
Alden Freddy in the cameras the reason
for golden Freddy being in here is that
nightmare I see I thought I just saw
something wall there the two eyes right
there I think that's actually nightmare
from five nights at Freddy's floor the
super cool anyway so it's got to be
something about golden Freddy here I was
doing something there I thought I had
something done I thought I did something
okay just come on in friend how you
doing welcome to the party golden
Freddy's right there
if golden Freddy's there maybe I honk
okay you're here no what does that mean
he was there too honking than the here
to view honk when he's in the camera
raises you
I thought something magical was about to
happen
honk um not shocking honking hey okay
alrighty then did I do this wasn't we
did that happen did I do I
all right I got it I think I got it
which way I guess I get to die then
okay okay so you had to find golden
Freddy and then honk instead of shock an
indeterminate number of times okay I
that depends on if that was that didn't
even look like a newspaper clipping what
was that said like come back or
something oh come back to us Nick Nick
Nixon what does that mean
so was Nick the arsonist so they're
looking for this missing man wake up
some newspaper clipping talking about
five nights at Freddy's new horror
phenomenon uh-huh police finally find
man serial arsonists were arrested come
back to us Nick these animatronics are
called the ignited these are the Fallen
these are the ignited these are the
fallen arsonist come back to us Nick
something that looks like golden Freddy
or Freddy in the outline what does it
mean is there some other piece of the
puzzle that I'm missing here what does
it mean that took forever oh man [ __ ]
anyway I didn't do that alone obviously
there was the huge hint of look for
golden Freddy and without that I
wouldn't have been able to do it but
with number four I thought it would have
been I with the basement I thought I
would have been in the room where golden
Freddy appeared on the screen and maybe
there's another piece of the puzzle
right there but I'm not on a percent
sure but anyway that is the end of the
game so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know if there's
something about these new newspapers
what does this mean there has to be
something else to this right and if
there's a compelling enough reason I
will force myself to do both of these
modes but I'll probably just do it in
one more episode because I don't want to
like milk this out or anything but this
was fun Oh as with all these puzzles I
want to know what the answer is and this
doesn't provide an answer so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I did in the comments below and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]